India has become the latest and largest
country to introduce a nationwide
lockdown in the fight against the
coronavirus its population of 1.3
billion has been told to stay at home
the country is so far seen about 560
confirmed cases and 11 deaths and there
are fears that infections could spread
quickly in densely populated urban areas
crowds formed at pharmacies and shops
shortly before the midnight deadline
non-essential businesses have been
closed and most flights and rail
services have been stopped and the busy
Bollywood film industry has ground to a
halt Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi
said without the 21-day lockdown the
country could be set back 21 years so
let's join DW correspondent nimisha
Joyce well in Delhi welcomed ameesha our
people are biting by these new
restrictions well to a large extent yes
people have not been coming out on the
streets as much as they normally would
have the Sunday voluntary curfew was
hugely successful with reports of
millions day but it's not quite as empty
on the streets right now because people
are allowed to step out to get essential
services but there are police
checkpoints across the city that are
preventing people who are not either
rendering or accessing essential
services from stepping out however it is
also important to think about the fact
that there are many amongst the urban
hood who are actually trying to get back
home now transport services are largely
shut down buses trains as well as
flights
however many are still trying to make
their way back to their home states
because their daily wage earners and
they cannot sustain themselves they
cannot afford life in the city anymore
and we went to find out how exactly
these people are managing walking large
distances in their efforts to get home
even though borders are closed this is
the report
these people are while eating a lockdown
Delhi has closed its borders no buses
trains or flights can leave yet
these migrant workers are determined to
get home many aren't just a daily wage
and with businesses shut they cannot
afford life in the city anymore with
public transport reduced Devraj has
walked many kilometers with his family
putting them at risk of exposure he's
scared but he says he has no option
letting me work that's the problem I
have young children they're hungry who
do I ask for help we've been struggling
for four days the Delhi government has
announced some relief measures for the
poor but these workers don't feel
reassured I can wait to find out if the
government will give me money but how am
I supposed to eat until then and what if
they don't
away from the bus stop the city lies
deserted those who can afford to are
staying home checkpoints like this one
have been established across the city
the police is ensuring that only those
who are rendering essential services are
allowed to be out the government has
also said that violators of the lockdown
can face legal action grocery stores
remain open some are only allowing a
limited number of shoppers in this one
says masks are necessity as is
sanitizing your hands before entering
India has been paralysed by these
measures but health experts are throwing
their weight behind the lockdown if
India can fight this together for two
weeks we definitely would have prevented
the curve from going up and made it flat
all that we need to do is to prevent the
curve from going the Italy way because
if that happens in India the results
will be much worse than what happened in
Italy
the Indian Prime Minister has appealed
to migrant workers to stay put and avoid
infecting their families back home but
for many that risk is far more distant
than being trapped away from home during
this lockdown the measure of the poor
always suffer worst in these crises tell
us more about how the government is
trying to help these migrant workers
well so the government has formed an
economic task force with the Finance
Minister at its helm to find out exactly
what would be the best route forward to
address the economic crises that are
sure to beset the country as a result of
this lockdown just yesterday some
regulatory and fiscal measures were
announced in addition the government has
asked all states to send funds to send
to add money to the bank accounts of
construction workers one of the main
constituents of the daily wage workers
but they're not the only ones and we
would have to wait and see how exactly
the government is going to ensure that
in the minutes to conduct our officials
can still make their way out and in
short says these daily wage workers and
the poorest of the poor in the country
are continuing to get meals and
sustenance during this lockdown thanks
for that Nimisha Joyce well in Delhi